every day
especially in the era of social media
from the mental health perspective
probably
the single worst invention of modern
times
we are likely to face enemies people who
disagree with us
people who tell us we're bad people who
say we should be ashamed of ourselves
or even be destroyed the common sense
advice
from well-meaning friends is just not to
listen
to shrug it off to assert that no one
cares
that the bully is mad or mentally unwell
and to suggest
a change of scene it's very kind and
sadly usually for many of us entirely
ineffective the question then emerges
why is it that some people find it
extremely hard to defend themselves
either in the sense of practically
answering back to an enemy
or simply of not caving in internally in
the face of an attack
why is it that when they're being
bullied at work some people are able to
mount a polite
calm fight back while others melt into
self-loathing and despair why is it that
if they're criticized unfairly in a
romantic context
some people are able to point out that
the criticism is not right
and get their side of the story across
and feel
steady and solid while others descend at
once
into paranoia we might put it like this
in order to be able to defend oneself
against an external foe
one has to be on one's own side
and this is not for some of us as easy
as it may sound
without us necessarily even quite
realizing the fact
our entire personalities may be geared
towards interpreting ourselves
as bad wrong a mistake
shameful and a piece of [ __ ] this may
sound dramatic
and we know in our intellectual adult
selves
that this can't be entirely right
nevertheless deep down
this isn't only slightly right it's the
fundamental truth about us
a first step towards dealing with an
external enemy
is realizing that our personalities are
built up in such a way
that we're going to have a big problem
on our hands
whenever we face opposition we should
expect to find this hard
and we do we are and there is no
pejorative association around this
whatsoever
a bit mentally unwell in this area
we therefore need to call for help
extend a lot of compassion to ourselves
and devote all the critical care we're
going to need to get through the crisis
we then need to take on board that
unfortunately
the real enemy we're harboring is not so
much currently
outside of us though they are there too
as inside of us we need to ask ourselves
why does the accusation feel so true
our conscious minds give us access to
only a fraction of the information
about us just as we can't intuitively
understand how a cell
operates in our very own body so the
makeup
of most of our emotional brain is sunk
in darkness
however there will be a history to our
self-loathing
we hate ourselves because somewhere
along the line
we were not properly loved somewhere in
the past
we heard a story you're a piece of [ __ ]
you don't deserve to be
f off and the story has stuck
how could someone facing an accusation
that they are an idiot
but who inside has a voice saying that
they're a [ __ ]
ever get the strength to defend
themselves they know in the adult part
of the mind
that they should be fighting back but
they can't because
inside all they hear is you are
everything your enemy
is saying you are and more they identify
entirely with their aggressor this can
get pretty
dangerous pretty fast if the external
enemy is vicious enough
and joins artfully enough with the
internal enemy
there can be suicidal thoughts and
perhaps suicide itself
the defenseless are the opposite of
self-righteous to their enemies they are
implicitly saying
i want to kill myself more than you ever
want to kill me
the solution to all this is a large
naive word
we'll have heard before but which we
need to grasp in its life-saving
dimension
love we need to hear often enough and
clearly enough
from other human beings and they don't
need to be romantic partners
the contrary to what the internal enemy
is saying
we are decent enough not perfect but
that isn't the criterion for deserving
to exist
we need to fix ourselves by absorbing
properly absorbing
the kindness of others the problem is
that people who feel their pieces of
[ __ ] aren't very
good at letting others take care of them
they don't know how to ask for help
and when help is given they may
initially push it away
accusing a kind friend of being weird or
inadequate
why after all would they be seeking to
help a freak
we know from the condition known as body
dysmorphia that it's no use telling
someone who feels they're disgusting
that they're in fact oh very nice
looking we need to help them to
understand
how they grew to hate themselves so much
and
show them via friendship that there
could be another way of relating to who
they are
we have some hints about how our minds
work from the way we acquire language
children fluently pick up incredibly
complex patterns of speech
from listening to those around them in
the early years
a parallel emotional process is going on
if someone when we were little was
speaking hate and shame
and guilt to us we will have started to
speak like that to ourselves
and it won't be easy in adulthood to
learn a new language
let alone to come to speak it fluently
to ourselves
telling someone mired in self-hatred to
cheer up or
like themselves a bit more is going to
be as impatient as telling someone from
england to
just speak bulgarian it's going to take
time
and a lot of training nevertheless if we
want to think about what an ambitious
project for humanity would look like
it would be a giant program of learning
to replace
the internalized languages of hate and
enmity
with those of love and compassion we've
been trying to do this for a couple of
millennia at least
but we've done a pretty poor job of it
so far and the project is more urgent
than ever
so we might start today by speaking a
few stumbling phrases of love
to the self-hating part of ourselves and
then to someone we know
near us who's perhaps right now mired in
shame and inadequacy at the school of
life we run regular virtual classes for
adults
these mini life courses cover such
topics as making relationships work
overcoming anger and anxiety career
guidance
finding meaning and purpose in life and
using culture as a therapeutic tool
click the link on screen now to learn
more